(ambient music)
- There's lots of amazing
weather phenomenon
happening all over our planet.
But what's going on
outside of our atmosphere?
My name is Leland Melvin
and as an astronaut,
I can tell you weather conditions in space
can be a matter of life and death.
Especially during a space walk.
When we prepare for a space walk,
we have to be able to
deal with temperatures
that range from positive 250
degrees Fahrenheit in the sun
and minus 250 degrees in the shade.
But in our space suit we have the ability
to withstand those temperature extremes
because we have visors
that reflect the sun
away from our eyes and
we have heated gloves
as well as a heated suit,
and then we have cooling
that allows us to stay cool
during those temperature extremes.
A solar flare is a sudden
flash of brightness,
observed near the sun’s surface
that emits X-ray and UV radiation.
In space, the radiation
levels can be deadly.
When we're notified of a solar
flare on the space station
we retreat to what we call the doghouse.
This doghouse is lined with water bags
that allow us to block
the radiation coming
from the sun before it gets to our bodies.
And that's where we go to keep
from getting exposed to
high-energy radiation.
As we go further out
into our solar system,
weather events become
more and more extreme.
Jupiter, our solar
system's biggest planet,
also features its most impressive storm.
The great red spot.
The gigantic tempest is
twice as wide as planet Earth
and has winds that reach
up to 400 miles per hour.
It's been swirling over
Jupiter for at least 150 years.
Further out, Neptune features
its own great big storm.
It takes up the planet's
entire atmosphere.
Neptune is our solar
system's windiest planet.
With wind speeds that can reach
up to 1,500 miles per hour.
That's nine times faster
than the strongest winds
ever recorded on Earth.
To find the strongest known
winds in our universe,
we have to go well
beyond our solar system.
Astrophysicists at York University
have discovered the
fastest winds ever recorded
near a super massive black hole.
These winds speeds clock in
at 125 million miles per hour.
I hope my crew never gets
caught up in anything like that.